speaking of Scooby-Doo this is going to
be a completely off topic note that I
don't even have written down I'm really
into the show called FBI right now
um it's like an NCIS or a CSI but it's
FBI cases instead I gotta say though
every other one is either a bombing or a
kidnapping and I'm like all right I
gotta get I get the point you guys are
the FBI but like
it's [__] switch it up a notch
grandma always says like if you miss an
episode of CSI it's okay because all the
episodes are exactly the same yeah yeah
so I'm really into the show FBI right
now and all of a sudden I'm watching an
episode and the dude who plays Shaggy in
the life like the real the live-action
Scooby-Doo is the killer in one of these
episodes yeah and he pops up and he's
somebody called who's called a family
Annihilator yeah who like there's like
four different types of them but they
they you know obviously they kill their
families for some sort of different
reason whether they're you know they're
doubting themselves or they're doubting
them or they're paranoid all that kind
of stuff right
and when we when I saw Shaggy on screen
and everything that was happening and it
cut to black and it was like Matthew
Lillard by the way is that his name
Matthew sorry for calling him shots
that's okay that's how I referenced them
he was also in the original screen
also true his discographies really good
and I think he's a great actor I agree
yeah I agree that's why I was I was
shocked to see him in something like
this uh playing this character which he
was really good in it so I I enjoyed it
but like right when it cut to black and
it was FBI and I knew that he was the
killer I was like like this is like
just killed my family and he just got in
to do by the way remind me never to do a
Shaggy impersonation with you that I
would lose that one oh yeah you'll lose
a Scooby-Doo and a Shaggy impersonation
for sure Matthew is amazing yeah and by
the way could not have found a better uh
Shaggy and by the way Matthew Lillard
it's interesting and having worked on
episodic shows and [__] in the writer's
room
when you say you're surprised to see him
on a show like that or just like playing
that role because I I don't think like
for me I've ever seen him in a legit
like serial killer murderer role went on
a killer oh is he one of the killers in
scream yeah that's right yeah I gotta go
back and watch all those because did you
see the most recent one that came out
yep really loved it I really liked it
actually and also the people who hadn't
seen it it gave you a really good
rundown of kind of like yeah the the
lore to it so I really enjoyed it but it
made me want to re-watch all of them